[Música]
y
por lo de mercedes y el presidente de
ucrania denuncia el hallazgo de una
nueva fosa común en medio de la invasión
rusa esta vez en la ciudad de siún
recientemente recuperada en la
contraofensiva de kiev más de 400
cuerpos habrían sido encontrados
mientras tanto la presidenta de la
comisión europea ursula von der leyen
realizó su tercera visita a la capital
ucraniana desde el inicio del conflicto
y reiteró el apoyo del bloque
comunitario al gobierno de kiev
y en mi grandes en situación irregular
en eeuu llegaron hoy a la residencia de
la vicepresidenta kamala harris y a una
isla frecuentada por altas figuras
demócratas es la más reciente maniobra
de los estados republicanos para poner
presión sobre los demócratas a menos de
dos meses de las elecciones de medio
término la casa blanca expresó su
rechazo
el adiós de su majestad el suizo roger
federer anunció su retiro del tenis
profesional después de competir en la
ley ver que a finales de septiembre en
londres en esta emisión analizamos la
trayectoria del que para muchos es el
más grande de todos los tiempos
tiempo de actualizarlas nos dices en la
pantalla de france 24 gracias por
continuar con nosotros mi nombre es juan
pupiales vamos a comenzar esta emisión
en ucrania porque presidente por los
díniz el skeet denunció el hallazgo de
una fosa común en la ciudad de sión una
de las urbes recientemente liberadas por
el ejercicio de el ejército de kiev en
su contraofensiva en la región clave
dejar kif en el noreste del territorio
en esta ocasión la policía regional
asegura haber encontrado más de 400
cuerpos y no es la primera vez que
ucrania reporta crímenes como estos por
parte de rusia en la actual guerra
se encontraron fosas comunes en misión y
en la región de jarque ya se iniciaron
los procedimientos legales necesarios
allí debería haber más información clara
y verificada mañana habrá periodistas
ucranianos e internacionales en misión
queremos que el mundo sepa lo que
realmente está sucediendo ya que ha
llevado la ocupación rusa en busán
mariupol y ahora desafortunadamente
misión
rusia está dejando muertes en todas
partes y debe ser responsable el mundo
debe llevar a rusia a la responsabilidad
real por esta guerra haremos todo por
esto
vistiendo los colores de la bandera de
ucrania la presidenta de la comisión
europea ursula von der leyen llegó hasta
aquí este jueves en la que es su tercera
visita al país desde el inicio de la
guerra la alta funcionaria habló de los
planes de integración del país en la
unión europea y aseguró que la libertad
tiene un costo posteriormente en una
entrevista aseguró que quiere que
vladimir putin enfrente consecuencias
por la invasión ante la corte penal
internacional este es el informe
una cálida bienvenida
el presidente ucraniano volodymyr
selenski recibió la presidenta de la
comisión europea úrsula von der leyen en
kiev los abrazos y las sonrisas marcaron
el encuentro uno que simbolizó su unidad
von der leyen incluso recibió un premio
del líder ucraniano
por su apoyo a la soberanía e integridad
territorial de ucrania entregamos el
premio jaroslaw mudry a ursula von der
leyen presidenta de la comisión europea
el viaje tenía un principal punto en la
agenda la adhesión de ucrania a la unión
europea el pasado mes de junio los 27
estados miembros aprobaron la solicitud
de adhesión de kiev un proceso que será
largo pero que va por buen camino
el proceso de adhesión va muy avanzado
[Música]
para la mente acordamos que teníamos que
trabajar al máximo para que ucrania
tengan más empresas más ingresos
así es como ucrania tendrá la
posibilidad de entrar en el mercado
común europeo de forma transparente
pero mientras tanto ucrania necesita
ayuda financiera es tomado por el
gobierno en 50.000 millones de dólares
al mes y más ayuda militar
por nuestra seguridad depende de nuestra
defensa aérea todos entendemos la
importancia de los sistemas de defensa
aérea pero no sé exactamente cómo
resolver este problema rápidamente
esta es nuestra máxima prioridad
en el frente del noreste del país la
contraofensiva ucraniana lanzada a
principios de septiembre ha permitido a
las fuerzas armadas recuperar casi toda
la región de jarquín de las manos de los
rusos
cambiamos de tema los presidentes de
rusia vladimir putin y de china xi
jinping coincidieron en la cumbre de la
organización de cooperación de shanghai
en uzbekistán se trata del primer viaje
al exterior para chip desde el inicio de
la pandemia la guerra en ucrania fue
tema central el mandatario ruso aseguró
comprender que su homólogo chino tenga
preguntas y preocupaciones sobre el
conflicto armado y le agradeció por lo
que calificó como una posición
equilibrada sobre un tema muy sensible
para moscú rafael pérez se nos cuenta
más
primer cara a cara de vladimir putin y
xi jinping desde el inicio de la
invasión rusa ucrania un momento
propicio para manifestar afinidades
el tándem de política exterior entre
moscú y beijing juega un papel clave
para garantizar la estabilidad global y
regional
result in agradeció además lo que llamó
una posición equilibrada por parte de
china en torno al conflicto en ucrania
al tiempo que condenó lo que calificó
como provocaciones por parte de eeuu en
el estrecho de taiwán por su parte y
extendió la mano a su interlocutor para
trabajar juntos en el escenario
internacional
ante un mundo una época y una historia
en constante cambio china está dispuesta
a esforzarse con rusia para asumir el
papel de grandes potencias y desempeñar
un papel de guía para inyectar
estabilidad y energía positiva en un
mundo sacudido por la agitación social
el encuentro sucedió en el contexto de
la cumbre de la organización de
cooperación de shanghai que comienza
oficialmente este viernes ambos
mandatarios han sostenido reuniones
bilaterales con varios jefes de estado
de las naciones asiáticas que pertenecen
al grupo entre las que destaca la
efectuada entre el presidente iraní
ebrahim raisi y el líder del kremlin
vamos hasta hungría porque en ese país
nuevas normas sobre el aborto entraron
en vigor este jueves en virtud de la
llamada exigencia del latido del corazón
las mujeres que interrumpen su embarazo
deben escuchar primero las señales de
vida del feto los grupos defensores de
los derechos reproductivos temen que sea
un paso más hacia la prohibición total
del aborto por parte del gobierno
ultraconservador
en un parque infantil en budapest estas
madres están consternadas dicen que
están angustiadas porque las personas
que interrumpen sus embarazos en hungría
deben ahora según la ley escuchar
primero los signos de vida del feto y
las vitales esto es un paso atrás
estamos volviendo a los tiempos antiguos
y en ávila grabados en antología no
puedo imaginar cómo el gobierno puede
decir esto sin más es absurdo
el decreto exige a los proveedores de
atención sanitaria que muestren a las
mujeres los signos vitales del feto de
forma que se identifiquen claramente
antes de poder realizar un aborto un
requisito defendido por el gobierno de
extrema derecha de viktor orbán que se
asemeja a las llamadas leyes del latido
del corazón en varios estados de eeuu
he traído este bebé como ilustraciones
de un niño de 10 semanas tiene manos
piernas puede chuparse los dedos y el
corazón late lo que demuestra que es un
ser vivo
esto evoca sida pero los ginecólogos
dicen que el término latido es
problemático porque en las primeras
etapas del embarazo aunque haya
actividad eléctrica el feto no tiene un
corazón funcional y que el sonido en
realidad es recreado por el ecógrafo
el aborto en hungría se legalizó en 1953
y se permite hasta las 12 semanas de
embarazo por motivos médicos o sociales
en el límite de 12 semanas puede
ampliarse en caso de defectos en el feto
los grupos de derechos reproductivos
temen que hungría pueda seguir los pasos
de la cercana a polonia que junto con
malta son los únicos dos países de la
unión europea donde el aborto está
totalmente prohibido
la política de algunos estados en
republicanos de enviar inmigrantes en
situación irregular a otros estados bajo
control demócrata dio un giro este
jueves el gobernador de la florida ronda
desfile todos aviones que llegaron a la
isla vacacional de martha's vineyard en
massachusetts y otra parte del
gobernador de texas envió dos buses
hasta las afueras de la residencia de la
vicepresidenta kamala harris en
washington dc la casa blanca denuncia
esta iniciativa el informe es de alva
santana
la crisis migratoria interna sigue en
eeuu el jueves un nuevo grupo de
emigrantes llegó de texas a washington
del autobús y esta vez con un destino
muy concreto la casa de la
vicepresidenta kamala harris
por esos seguros gente vivo
creo que es un verdadero desastre creo
que es horrible cómo está utilizando la
gente como peores tipos y es que texas
ya ha transportado en autobús a más de
7000 migrantes a washington dice ya
nueva york desde abril algo que ha
supuesto un gasto de al menos 13
millones de dólares su objetivo hacer
recaer la responsabilidad de los
migrantes sobre estados gobernados por
demócratas una acción que usa a personas
con fines políticos
hay una forma legal de hacer esto y de
gestionar a los inmigrantes que los
gobernadores republicanos prefieran en
este proceso y utilicen a los
inmigrantes como peones políticos es
vergonzoso imprudente y simplemente
incorrecto
una acción a la que otros gobernadores
republicanos como ron de santis en
florida se han sumar mandando a un grupo
de inmigrantes a la isla de martha's
vineyard en avión una región rica en la
que suelen veranear demócratas
relevantes como el ex presidente barack
obama
nuestro mensaje para ellos es no somos
un estado santuario es mejor poder ir a
una jurisdicción santuario y si te
ayudaremos a facilitar ese transporte
para que puedan ir a pastos más verdes
una situación que también ha violentado
a los migrantes esperando que
a menos de dos meses de las elecciones
del 8 de noviembre en florida y texas
muchos tachan este movimiento como el
último intento de los republicanos para
ganar votos
un veterano jurista de nueva york es el
perito independiente designado por una
jueza federal para que sirva como una
tercera parte en la revisión de los
documentos incautados al expresidente de
eeuu donald trump en su residencia de
florida
se trata de ramón javi quien fue
designado por la jueza federal del
distrito sur de la florida el link canon
es una decisión que va en contra del
pedido del departamento de justicia que
había solicitado la suspensión de un
fallo que había prohibido al fbi avanzar
con la investigación de un centenar de
documentos clasificados encontrados en
mar halago propuesta canon fue designada
por el propio donald trump en el año
vamos a argentina porque la
vicepresidenta cristina fernández de
kirchner habló por primera vez desde el
intento de homicidio en su contra el
primero de septiembre durante un
encuentro con sacerdotes aseguro que
está viva por dios y por la virgen y
dijo que lo ocurrido pudo haber
representado una ruptura del acuerdo
social y del orden democrático hizo
también un llamado a erradicar los
discursos de odio de otra parte una
jueza dictó prisión preventiva para los
principales sospechosos de haber
intentado atentar contra la funcionaria
shabak montiel y su novia aprenda un
lear de fueron procesados como coautores
de intento de homicidio calificado
mi primera
actividad pública por así decirlo o
fuera
de un despacho fuera con ustedes yo
siento que estoy viva por dios y por la
vida realmente el papá francisco me
llamó bien tempranito al otro día
de s
desde ese jueves el viernes tempranito
me llamo estuvimos hablando por teléfono
y me dijo algo así como que
los actos de odio los actos de odio y de
violencia
siempre son precedidos por palabras y
por verbos de odio y de violencia
la leyenda del tenis roger federer
anunció este jueves su retiro del tenis
profesional
el suizo abandonará el tenis competitivo
después de la ley ver cap que termine el
próximo 25 de septiembre en londres
previamente hablamos con sebastian freis
periodista deportivo y autor de los
libros sin red y el roger federer y
rafael nadal the lives and kerber
softbol tenis legends le preguntamos
sobre cómo cambio federer el juego y de
si es el mejor de todos los tiempos
hola buenas noches bueno el tenis tiene
un antes y un después de heather no se
puede entender el tenis de los últimos
años y no se puede entender la
popularidad que ha logrado el tenis en
los últimos años sin roger federer que
fue además la mitad de una gran
rivalidad que es esa rivalidad que se
gestó con rafael nadal básicamente feder
ha sido el tenista perfecto el estilo
con estilo muy clásico pero a la vez muy
moderno muy potente muy ofensivo y ha
sido una persona en su actuación pública
en su
movimientos públicos intachable y eso no
era lo habitual en el tenis donde si
recordamos fin de los 70 principio de
los 80 estaba repleto de 'bad boys'
desde mca raro a becker siempre había
problemas no era el caso con federer que
era un ejemplo dentro de la cancha y
también una vez que los partidos
terminaban en cuanto a lo que pueda
decirse si fue o no el mejor de la
historia los peñistas y el mismo suele
responder que en la historia
la historia es muy larga que hay que
comparar épocas por lo tanto federer
para muchos puede haber sido el mejor de
esta época otros crean que fue nadal
otros quedan que fue djokovic pero lo
que sí se puede decir de fer es que no
hubo ni habrá ninguno como él y eso sí
es que es hacerse grande en la historia
ninguno como federer o así terminamos
esta emisión informativa en la pantalla
de france 24 quédense porque la
información continúa aquí y también en
france 24 punto com
[Música]